all might is in a battle to the death
with his old rival all for one all
foran's body is slowly being rewound out
of existence by the effects of Aries
Quirk but while that means that his time
is limited it also means that he is now
back to his physical peak and that he is
much stronger than he was in commo all
might is using a new high-tech battles
suit in order to fight all for one
despite not having a quirk but while
he's been putting up an impressive fight
the hints that he is about to die are
everywhere all might is already severely
injured but he keeps pushing himself
because he wants to help deu and the
Next Generation his life already flashed
before his eyes he remembered c n eyes
prophecy about his death and more the
manga is strongly foreshadowing that
this is the end of all might and we are
not ready for what happens next if you
want to be the first to know what
happens next subscribe to anime uproar
right now